guardians of the galaxy vol 1 is a
basket full of Easter eggs now a video
uploaded to YouTube by new rock stars in
which Eric vas shines light on what
might be the film's infamous still
missing Easter egg has inspired a
compelling tweet from writer director
James Gunn when asked by a fan if new
rock stars had found the final Easter
egg he replied they have found a big
piece of it yes let's get down to brass
tacks basically if James Gunn's tweets
can be trusted it turns out that Peter
Quill's mom may or may not be a cosmic
being who helped craft the Infinity
stones
there are several moving parts to this
idea the first is that when Peter grabs
hold of the power stone at the end of
guardians volume 1 an act he's capable
of doing thanks to his half celestial
identity which he got from his father
ego the Living Planet
when Gamora cries out for him to take
her hand Peter suddenly sees his mother
as she appeared in the hospital bed
while she was dying of cancer
in his vision momma quill repeats take
my hand Peter when that moment happened
in real time while Peter was still a boy
he refused meredith's and
[Music]
the other part aims to offer another
possible reason for Peters ability to
hold the power stone explain the further
significance of seeing his mother
envisions and detail how that connects
to a quartet of cosmic entities boss
theorizes that the reason why Peter can
grasp the power stone is because his
dearly departed mom might be a powerful
cosmic entity herself one who once took
the human form of Meredith quill in an
attempt to prove this loss points to a
piece of artwork on the temple vault
wall on Morag that depicts four entities
death entropy eternity and infinity
seemingly forging the six Infinity
stones Peter is present during this
moment in guardians of the galaxy volume
1 and actually mentions one of the
entities eternity in Guardians volume 2
during the scene in which ego opens
Peters eyes to the universe he says
[Applause]
if Peter had seen his mother in a vision
during a pivotal moment in guardians
volume one could seeing eternity during
a similar time in Guardians vol 2 signal
that Meredith quill is eternity one of
the beings who created the Infinity
stones it's certainly a juicy morsel to
chew on and there is an additional
tidbit and Guardians the galaxy vol 1
that could support this idea when Peter
has a vision of her Meredith is set
against a cosmic background that's
slowly piecing itself together the
colors of her backdrop resembled nowhere
the place where the collector has
headquartered his operation in a
celestial skull back in 2017 youtuber
master tainment guessed that the
coordinates under guardians volume ones
locations intertitles could be
translated since then Marva lights have
managed to decode the messages of
several locations claiming that the
message beneath nowhere spells out
Meredith quill X there's been no
confirmation of this from Gunn that we
did note that a list of four intertidal
translations that included Meredith
quill X was about 70% correct it's
unclear which of the four fan
translations are fully or partially
accurate it's also worth noting that the
fan who presented the Meredith quill X
translation a gun has now changed it to
Meredith quill ABBA
a guest to which gun hasn't responded it
goes without saying that this would be
incredibly cool for this to all add up
to the mysterious guardians of the
galaxy vol 1 Easter Egg but the truth of
the matter is that nothing has been
officially confirmed guns amazing work
comment could have been in reference to
any number of topics discussed in the
video or could have been a blanket
statement about the quality of the video
as a whole his note that Voss and the
new rockstars team uncovered a big piece
of the highly sought for Easter egg
doesn't definitively quantify accuracy
in any way what defines big sixty
percent ninety who knows there's also
the fact that this kind of surprise
Firenze already L has already been done
my name is ego
and I'm your dad bitter
[Music]
while Marvel isn't immune to revisiting
certain themes and even giving in to
some tropes doing the exact same thing
twice to one character feels like it'd
be a cheap shot plus the fact that
eternity in the Marvel Comics has never
had a secret identity as Meredith quill
also doesn't inspire a lot of confidence
that this is what's actually going on
Peter Quill's mom being a cosmic entity
who had a hand in creating the Infinity
stones would serve as a huge retroactive
bombshell on the Marvel Cinematic
Universe connecting her to the Avengers
franchise in particular in a major way
given that the final Avengers flick was
focused on the heroes obtaining the
stones from points in the past to power
an Infinity Gauntlet in the present and
would probably have significant impacts
on where the MCU is headed next
Marvel isn't the type of company to make
willy-nilly decisions without careful
forethought however so in the unlikely
event that this does end up being the
truth fans should expect a detailed
breakdown of Meredith's real identity in
a future film just don't hold your
breath waiting for that day to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]